[Music]
this season on the drew barrymore show
one working girl takes on the world
you know i have a head for business and
a bod for
single-breasted suits
with her signature passion and appetite
for life
this sandwich it's so
good it is so
good it's the best sandwich i have ever
had
i think i'll have one of those as a
matter of fact you make it a double
whether you're a miranda looking for her
steve
or just a slice of pizza
cheers i love you i love you
[Music]
this season will leave you sleepless
with excitement thanks to a little help
from the drew crew it's you
it's me
star egg interior designer mikel welch
chef hilar valdez
co-anchor ross matthews
and host drew barrymore
in the drew barrymore show
season two
welcome home
it's week two of our premiere event
back in new york city with celebrities
it is really hard to contain my
excitement new york's best bites
plus evan hansen meets josie grossi
and today on drew fran drescher
surprises aquafina the two queens of
queens it all starts now
please welcome drew barrymore
[Applause]
oh my god thank you
thank you
i don't
i don't know if anyone got a glimpse of
uh the beginning of season one
but uh i went real hard
by myself here i looked nuts we were all
nuts it was september of 2020. we had
this really intimate setting
and yet one day we hoped that maybe we
could ever get here
so to our very first new york studio
audience thank you so much
thank you thank you so much
it's a total dream
one i never thought we'd get to but here
we are in our season two
and it is such a privilege to be back in
um
my new hometown of new york i love it
here so much
i don't know if you can tell from my
accent but i'm from california
and um we're just celebrating everything
about hometowns we kicked off in my
hometown of los angeles and
we're here now and you know i just want
to celebrate the whole country
and
celebrate the fact that there is no
place like home and that emotional
storytelling for me is going to be a
huge thread for this season and we
actually get to leave the studio
so i want to take it as far vast and
wide as they'll possibly let us and here
we are starting in new york and um
our first guest couldn't be more true
to um
the storytelling and the thematic nature
of new york because
she hails from queens um she is a rapper
a golden globe winner
and you know superstar from like
blockbuster hits like crazy rich
[Applause]
best movie asians
i have seen that movie 50 times um she's
in the uh amazing movie farewell for
which she won a golden globe
and she's most recently in the number
one film across the entire globe uh
chongqi
so i know
her star just continues to rise and you
can catch her on her show on comedy
central which i love so much nora from
queens take a look
we are hot
i look more like owen wilson than i do
cameron diaz
selfie
all right i was gonna take it
oh okay we literally don't have time for
this we have 23 stops tonight let's go
how many steps
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god i love new york in the
building right i mean queens you are a
queen and you're from queens that's
fitting yeah i appreciate that
you know another queen from queens uh
is uh lucy lou and
i wanted to ask you because lucy
had meaning for you back in the day and
i would just love to hear
from you
like what that was because i i love her
and i love you and so i'm like in the
middle just wanting to know
how that story came out
lucy lou was and charlie's angels uh was
like the
the pinnacle of like
everything to me and to see lucy in in a
role like that um was really momentous
it changed the way that i looked at
myself in the world and um
i will say that i don't think that i
would have i would be where i am truly
without without um
seeing lucy lou do her thing back in the
day
it's good when i watch nora from queens
and your storytelling is so strong the
way
you know heart to humor to me has to
have heart it's like i but i want humor
to push
how do you have the bravery to push that
humor so far because you go there you
don't compromise you're such a badass
you know i i agree i think all humor
needs to have
kind of heart at its baseline a lot of
the things that i i talk about in my
show
are a mixture of reality or like what i
would imagine
you know my my my family or or or what
like what they would say
so i try to stick to that what's so
amazing is in that very same episode you
will break my heart
and make me emotional you know when you
talk about
your grandma and you did grow up in
queens with your grandma and will you
tell us about that time of your life
she's was definitely
not
you know your ordinary parent i think
like you know she really
kind of noticed that the spunk in me and
i remember i was i was to ask her like i
feel weird grandma i feel like i don't
fit in i feel like uh you know i people
people think certain things about me and
i just feel weird and she's she always
told me the weirdness in you
um is inevitably what's going to make
you different and what's going to make
you special she always told me that you
know she was always a big fan but she
was also
you know like we we got into shenanigans
together as well
um you know uh we we there was a
carnival that would come to town for
instance and she didn't want to pay the
admissions fee so they gave out these
bracelets with like little designs on
them and she was like let's just buy a
marker and white paper and i'll just
tape it to your arm and we'll make your
admission bracelets so i don't got to
pay like 10 bucks to get you in
and so so
i love that story so much and isn't it
true when you were like 16 she also told
you something
she'll be like you're 10 years old so
that we can go to the buffet and you can
get a child's discount
um and she she literally would like slap
a backwards cap on me and it's like what
like what is this what is a backwards
cap just just code for i'm a kid yes but
it worked um okay another
total juxtaposition was something i was
hoping that you could share with our
audience because i just thought it was
such a hot tip and we could all benefit
from it it's a beauty tip that you gave
to a lore magazine with your gorgeous
cover that was so unique and dynamic
um absolutely i there so if you ever
need a makeup blotter or like a face
splotter just go to any airport and just
take a toilet seat cover
because that's what that is
yes girl
yes you can put your head through it too
that's a necklace it's true yes you're
all done you could
and then you could actually make it
fashion
and then
there you go and it's a bib you changed
my life with this tip so i just want to
thank you because i'm never looking at
these suckers the same way
[Applause]
we're gonna go to a quick commercial
break if that's okay um and when we come
back i'd like to play a little game with
you aquafina beautiful nora
um with someone else who is a very
special queens native and i'm very
excited about this we'll be right back
i thought you should play against
another true blue queens native please
welcome the legendary fran drescher
[Applause]
i'm so happy to be included in this
queen of queensland
i love you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back with the amazing iconic and
totally dope aquafina and in honor of
nora from queens and aquafina being from
queens i thought that maybe we could
play a little trivia game to test how
much you really know about your hometown
your game
yeah okay i i really hope i know about
my hometown yeah it's a little game
we're calling queen of queens
[Applause]
now since i'm not from queens um i
thought you should play against another
true blue queens native please welcome
the legendary fran drescher
[Applause]
wow
oh hi everyone
i can't believe i'm here right now
i love both you girls i'm so happy to be
included in this queen of queensland
i love you so much i was like i'm in a
queen of queensland i should be your
neighbor
on the show
yes
i'm setting
[Applause]
maybe it's the love connection that
we're playing
aquafina from queens i mean you're
carrying the torch girl and i'm really
really thrilled oh
thank you where where
do can we break away from where
in queens are you
flush are you
you're from flushing that's crazy did
you go to did you go to alums
of course that's where my sister's sweet
16 was
what
[Applause]
that's my family's restaurant it's so
cool
[Applause]
you know fran i was reading something
that you said once is it true
that like
one television executive said to you
like your voice i don't know
and then another person was like it's
because of you your voice your
personality that this is gonna work
yes actually you know i i mean all along
the road people said that the voice was
going to hold me back and it was peter
jacobson my writing producing partner
and my beloved gay ex-husband
said uh-uh that's you know the voice the
face
the comic timing that's what's going to
make you a star and we're going to lean
into it
we're not going to try and dilute it or
move away from it and and he was right
you know i'm really grateful but back in
the day when we had sold the idea for
the show
they actually said can the character be
italian and not jewish right
and uh said you know
we said now that you know we couldn't
write it as authentically i i know i
know how to be jewish we know how to
write jewish that's the way we have to
go and i kind of just even though i knew
it was my big break we said
you know no because i don't i don't like
to have regret and i thought if i go
along with this idiotic suggestion and
it doesn't fly i'm going to be kicking
myself why did i listen to them so you
know i just kind of make it a cardinal
rule that i go with my god and i try and
convince everybody why i think it's the
right idea
rather than
play please well i thank you both for
putting out shows
authentic to who you are and changing
the world to welcome other people to
find that confidence and do the same so
thank you for that thank you
thank you
thank you
and
so your origin story starts in queens
we're going to play a game you guys are
going to take turns answering
questions with multiple choice options
and the person with the most correct
answers wins the queen of queens let's
get to it the first question goes to
aquafina
aquafina
what famous magician is buried in a
cemetery in queens is it a
david copperfield b william ellsworth
robinson c
magicians can't always be put in a box
they can escape
or d harry houdini i want to say houdini
but i feel like it's it might be
copperfield or the or c
oh god they're gonna come the magicians
are gonna come after me the magicians
are going to come houdini you okay with
terry houdini
okay
[Applause]
oh look he's got crowns falling from the
sky okay fran what neighborhood of
queens did cindy lauper grow up in was
it ozone park
a b jackson heights c girls just want to
have flushing or d sunnyside
i'm gonna say ozone park
you are right
yes
yes
[Applause]
okay aquafina which one of these people
of note was not born in queens
a howard stern b tony danza c laurie
laughlin or d al roker
oh oh man
i almost want to say
howard stern
but
i don't know i don't know can i can i
have a lifeline can i take a lifeline
forget can i take your friend what do
you think what do you think it is
i think your first instincts are right
i'm gonna say how it starts
well you'll both be interested to know
it's b tony danza he was not born in
queens
oh he was born in brooklyn
okay france turned which subway line
runs through queens a the six train b
the d train c the a train d idk
i'm gonna guess the d
it's the d it is the a train
the a train goes to queens
apparently
okay it does it goes
all right this score is tied a while
since i've taken the subway
you know i've been stuck in a train car
with fans there's no way out you know
no yeah no yeah okay last question goes
to aquafina what part of queens did the
nanny take place in a astoria b forest
hills c
flushing d drescher island
well let's see right yes
[Applause]
the flashy girl from flushing the nanny
named fran
well the accumulative winner is aquafina
today but you are both
queens two
amazing queens who have changed the
world
three greens three queens
aquafina and fran drescher i am so
honored to be in your queen's sandwich
right now
and
may we all be able to come together
again as soon as possible nora from
queens wednesdays at 10 9 central on
comedy central and the wonderful
magnanimous fran drescher thank you
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
all season long we're highlighting home
towns all across the country because
there's no place like home
next step is seattle washington where
marley and anthony love call home
the loves love seattle and i have a
feeling we're about to also watch this
[Music]
hey drew it's anthony marley and we're
in front of pike place market located in
our hometown of seattle washington drew
we love seattle so much not just because
of the great scenery and great coffee
but there's some places that mean so
much to us personally so come with us
and let us show you around
[Music]
we are at the iconic space needle a
signature staple for the seattle skyline
of course it's iconic but it's personal
for us because on our first trip to
seattle in 2015
this was the spot when we decided that
we were gonna move to seattle and now it
just represents the love that we have
for this city
[Music]
welcome to boom bunna coffee boom boona
is a local seattle coffee shop that
specializes in african coffee before
moving to seattle we only drank the name
brand stuff but locals told us hey you
have to try a local spot boom booner was
the first one and we fell in love now
that we got some coffee let us take you
to another spot that is personal to us
[Music]
we're from the aokai beach one of many
beaches located right here in seattle
yeah there are so many beautiful beaches
in seattle you really can't go wrong but
aokai is our personal favorite not only
because it was the first beach that we
visited when we moved to seattle but
look at those breathtaking views
also visitors can play volleyball walk
run or ride on the paved path laid along
the beach on top of all that right
across from the beach are great options
for food and fun with plenty of
restaurants bars and shops alki beach
another reason why we love seattle
well drew that's just a snapshot of this
beautiful city of seattle we hope you
love it as much as we do we can't wait
for you to come visit see you soon
i love you loves and by the way i never
go to seattle without hitting pikes
market and having a bowl of the best
clam chowder ever
oh what a wonderful place i love seattle
and hometowns and i love this country
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back our next guest became
a viral sensation on tick-tock
for breaking into someone's home but
it's not what you're thinking because
we're not advocating that here he didn't
actually take anything from the house
not even a little
but he did leave it spotless after
spending two and a half hours cleaning
it from top to bottom yeah i know this
is such a wild story check this out
so
my friend tells me that one of his
co-workers wants me to clean his
apartment so i go there today
and
he tells me that there's a key under the
map get the key go into the apartment
clean the entire apartment so he calls
me and he's like yo where are you and i
was like um i'm in your living room
waiting for you to walk in i'm playing
with your cat
he goes
uh man
i don't have a cat
what
so comes to find out that i cleaned the
wrong apartment and broke in and cleaned
somebody's random apartment
you're welcome
please say hello to louie angelino
so how did this happen so i was off by
one digit it was only one number
227 instead of 277. um
and i had just assumed that i was going
to the right address
um but it just so happened that
there was two keys under both of the
mats which is insane because what are
the odds that there's going to be two
keys on the same time in the same day
under both mats
how did you even get into the taking
care of people's homes um
to be completely honest with everything
that happened with kovid i was feeling
very like uninspired and um
she's in the audience right now my best
friend joe duran's mom and my mother are
in the office
that is them they are the ones that my
mom ever since i was a kid has always
told me clean room clean mind and diana
who looks so lovely today
um
told me she came up with the idea
to
pay me like 50 bucks a week to just to
keep the apartment clean for
for her and and my best friend and
started out with that
and through doing that i would just you
know i would go in there with my
bluetooth speaker and i'm jamming out
and i'm dancing and i'm swiffering and
i'm having so much fun and i don't even
realize that i'm cleaning i was at a
very dark place and at that time i
didn't have a car i didn't have a job i
really didn't have a purpose
and they gave me that thank you guys so
much for giving that type of advice
and direction and being such positive
influences
and i want to celebrate things like this
in the world and you know you have this
new passion and you're going to pursue
this as a career i would love to that
would be the dream all right well i know
that you started a gofundme page to help
kick start your cleaning career and your
giving and your altruism and your taking
care of people and we just want to help
you continue that and foster that um so
our friends at safely are giving you ten
thousand dollars
[Applause]
and that is not only a year's worth of
supplies but we'd love to feature you on
our website and help build your business
oh my god
thank you
where do i sign my soul to you you
already did oh girl oh my god
you already did thank you so much it's
really a big thing for my mental health
and like that's one thing i wanted to
mention is that i know everybody
somehow someway battles with something
that goes on up here and if something is
keeping a clean environment
can help somebody like me with mental
health it can help out somebody else too
and and that's just that's so important
for me because mental health
really finally i think we're at a point
where it's being taken seriously yeah i
think athletes talking about it is
really amazing because
if they're saying they struggle
i i think there's a lack of bias
sometimes or maybe a greater openness to
understanding that even the strongest
people go through it
but i think we also need to hear from
everybody about how important that
mission is i mean i see you building a
whole business that also recruits other
people like let's get this going louie
all right let's go all right let's go
thank you louie go on the drewberrymart
show.com to learn more about louise
amazing business and thank you for
safely giving ten thousand dollars to
louie's cause we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back we are celebrating
hometowns all across the country all
season long and this week we're loving
on my new hometown new york city
all right well there's five boroughs and
it feels almost impossible to experience
everything that the city has to offer
but that didn't stop us from trying one
burrow at a time
i met up with my new bestie i am not
kidding fat joe
who's such a good human oh my god i see
why everybody worships him and he took
me on a tour of his native bro
the bronx let's take a look
hey everyone we're here in the bronx
with the grammy-nominated musician
entrepreneur and bronx native and he is
about to take us on the ultimate bronx
tour i just can't wait to meet him and
i'm actually gonna meet him right now
welcome to the bronx bad job
[Applause]
i think i'm gonna record this show and
play that intro back every morning for
motivation where are we going first
this is the number one italian bakery in
the bronx let's go
i'm so excited
[Music]
oh wow
there's cookies with our faces on it
shout out to the staff about two so
believe it or not they specialize in all
desserts the favorite thing of mine here
is birthday cakes do we get to try the
birthday cake big time
oh
my gosh that is this is beautiful home
is where you are wow
you've been married 26 years 26 years
yeah
it's been real joe give me a word of
wisdom about longevity and marriage when
you meet the person you love a switch
goes off where you say
this is it
because i had no money when i met her i
lived in an apartment and i only had a
mattress and so we made the pass i said
listen if we get successful we're never
going to leave each other we're never
going to change on each other joe there
are so many things i want to keep
talking to you about let's go to the
next location and we'll pick another
profound dope subject this guy is
amazing we're going to jimmy spa con
sofrito to give you that real authentic
porter you can't you can't get really
than this
jimmy is a living legend he make these
recipes and mix things up that no one
would ever think of in the latin
community now this is sancocho
it's a hearty soup meat and starches and
root vegetables i am so excited okay
here we go you guys this is my very
first fight
[Music]
how does that thing
stop come on
you gotta stop
you know this is the best i've been
collecting sneakers my whole life for 20
something years and so we're about to go
to my newest store that hasn't even
we're gonna reveal it on your show it's
called up nyc the bronx
and uh let's get going over there break
out the kliq lights we have a premiere
coming let's go
voila
after you
so this is the latest creation up nyc
the third store we're in the south bronx
we wanted to do something really really
beautiful for the community you know a
lot of people
who get successful whether they're
famous or they're entrepreneurs the
dream is to leave the hood and most of
them never come back the thing that i
like is we create a hub a safe place for
the community showing that the future
entrepreneurs are successful people that
come from the hood you can be successful
move out but you could come back and
just give inspiration and give hope i am
really like just insanely overly
impressed let me show you this room over
here we have a learning center for kids
that don't have access to computers that
i'm gonna have my successful friends
come
once a month and give them a a
a motivational for the kids and the
project's right across the street so let
me let me show you juice so you can see
that this is real
it's the projects affordable housing
across the street it's time that people
take our community serious and invest
back
and show them the love that they need
and the support they need what do you
think attributes the most
to being such a good person i just read
them been through so much in life that
we have no choice but god has blessed me
and my family but to give back to my
community and just offer them hope or
inspiration if i got something for you
that's you
know
[Music]
oh thank you we love you too
number love y'all
these are some dunks called new york
versus new york all the street
basketball parks are down here it's just
a gift from us to you you know up nyc
you know because we love you and we
thank you appreciate you for all the
love you showing us this is such a big
deal that i'm gonna get a pair of
sneakers from you right now like
i mean i just can't it's like we're in
england and i'm being knighted by the
queen i mean you've definitely been
knighted in the bronx
thank you for literally making me
the coolest person amongst my friends
what do you think those are fly and they
match i'm gonna do
oh
man
[Music]
oh joe i love you so much i love you so
much
and uh that joe he hooked us up with
some cool sneakers so we thought we'd do
the same for all of you i mean i have
sneakers from fat joe you i have so much
cred now it's not even funny all right
so everyone in our studio audience is
going to get a pair of bessie shoes
what's really cool about these is
they're 100 waterproof oh that's sexy in
this city
um and vegan which is also so good
and also
let's face facts i didn't wear these
shoes on a borough tour if you're going
to walk around new york do yourself a
favor wear something doable comfortable
and stylish
and go to any neighborhood that you want
and enjoy yourself and we'll be right
back
[Music]
welcome back it's time for drew's news
your scrappy little good news program
just trying to make it in a big city
and with me at the desk my fierce and
trusty co-pilot ross matthews we're back
everybody our first new york audience
well it's good to be home but we can't
get too comfortable because we're taking
our little new show on the road later
this week
uh we're uh drew's newsing from philly
hey philly we're coming up yeah maybe
some cheese steaks and uh
um and then um we're also coming from
our nation's capital washington d.c
it's
it's so epic yeah we have we have a news
desk we will travel so if you want us to
come to your city hit us up on social
media maybe you'll see us right there
that's right have desk will travel hit
us up please welcome us or request us
i can't wait for philly in dc i know
i know well there's no better way to
kick off this news than when one of the
biggest superstars in digital comedy
right now
he's got millions of followers on
instagram who are absolutely hooked on
his incredible characters he recently
took his talents to washington as well
here's a look at benito skinner
hey everyone
vogue
usually i start off with a big coffee
sorry they're like really strict in here
hey jenny i booked you a nail
appointment love yeah i didn't tell you
to do that it's called initiative
hi white house is a scooper um i don't
think so
oh it doesn't matter
[Music]
oh thank you honey
these suck sophie on xcx put on
chemtrails anastasia get out here for
your swim lesson honey
[Applause]
please welcome back to the show benito
skinner aka betty drama wow
literally like i'm in heaven oh my god
you're the biggest deal in the world i'm
so oh i can't i will never and by the
way i posted your video that you did uh
you do danielle from ever after the film
i was in and you're dead
that movie is my favorite movie ever the
wings no it was my fantasy give me one
line as daniel oh my god well i think i
have to do just like
breathe
just
breathe
no it was that was my fantasy come to
life i yeah it was an honor all right
well let's jump into the news um hey oh
we gotta talk about this we're you know
we're back in the city and all summer
long the talk of the town has been
sex and the city are you ready sjp
cynthia nixon and kristen davis they're
shooting the hbo max spin-off and just
like that which is what it's called and
vanity fair reports you can get all the
leaked info you need on instagram and
online there have been tons of photos of
the ladies on set revealing new cast
members like nicole arie parker and
shots of carey in bed with mr big
and um okay i feel
torn about this because i am looking
forward to this more than anything i've
ever looked forward to in my entire life
and i feel like about these leaks they
feel like how like dessert for me you
know like i devour it and then i just
feel bad about my choices because i
i i want to wait i want to see the whole
thing when it comes out thoughts no it
so okay so i also devour it it's kind of
like if like music leaks and i'm like i
can't touch that like the artist
wouldn't want me to and then i'm like
play it again
all right well your story next benny oh
my god my turn next we're going to talk
about the latest dating term on this one
uh wait how do you guys do this
i feel like i'm in like fifth grade i
have to read in front of the class by
the way if someone told me like just
come up with a character out of thin air
i would feel the same way so okay
okay my turn next we're going to talk
about the latest dating term on the
block why am i reading this like that
roaching
[Laughter]
like literally i'm kris jenner character
style reports um roaching refers to when
the person you're dating is sleeping
with a ton of other people and not
telling you about it that's also called
being a horrible person
there's a really simple thing you can
say if you know of even just one person
he's hooking up with other than you
get out the raid spray it
drew
have you ever been roached oh well i
mean i just assume here's the deal i i
think unless you're exclusive you're not
exclusive you know so you should just
assume uh you get enroached and
ironically it doesn't bug me i think pun
intended yes totally intended i just
think until you have that convo of like
you and me and no one else right yeah
you just should sort of just
accept the facts that they're getting it
but i do like when new vernacular comes
into our zeitgeist and we can now say oh
she's roaching he's a roach i think
that's fun i think it's fun too and
honestly like it's it has the right like
tenor like the tone for what you're
doing you are roaching yeah like you're
vile you're a roach but uh
we have something else to do though i'm
very excited because um
we built a brand new digital studio it's
upstairs it is stunning it is gorgeous
it's fun giving me like mtv and the 80s
vibes and we are so lucky because benny
you are going to be our very first
you're going to christen it and we are
going to do it together so thank you for
uh doing the inaugural digital piece
with us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back
okay it's almost time to go but we
couldn't be more thrilled and truly
honored to be back in our hometown of
new york city and it is a big moment yes
i heart new york indeed and we've got
someone special here to help us
celebrate he is a musician and someone
that you must follow right now in the
doggy bag
[Music]
there he goes he's added a very rich
soundtrack of the city as a street
performer for many years with the socks
that could just stop your heart please
welcome auggie bellow
[Applause]
thank you so much i'm so excited to be
here we're so excited you're here thank
you so much you bring so much joy what's
your favorite part of doing what you do
so with every morning i wake up trying
to make someone smile and if i could do
that through music or if you're making
someone laugh then that's a day worth
living for me oh come on
[Laughter]
it hurts it hurts this is what it is
this is the good stuff this is this is
worth
the search because these are the rewards
it's someone like you thank you so much
it means the world to me auggie thank
you for being here everybody thank you
for being here
rossi i love you love you
auggie take it away
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you